[Music]
we brought together six gamers I'm a
gamer I'm a gamer now in the game
I am a gamer I am a gamer I'm a gamer
one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize if the liar
survives they win the entire prize
[Music]
quick question if you're a real gamer
what is this pose called Oh t-posts I
trust everyone else got steel yes
absolute unit with a picture of a buff
community
novalee it's three five seven and mine
spicy chicken have you that here with a
picture of Lucy hurt
Oh what do I got might million-pound PC
though I mainly paid over what I do okay
Oh week I'm I'm like very into
simulation game so I play a lot of like
The Sims I do variety so I play league
but I also play everything from like
Pokemon to dungeons like anything except
horror I like a lot of like 90s for us
those right now I'm playing haunting
just like do you guys are you guys
familiar with haunting
[Music]
all right so this is the first round but
we had a time it's between Jessica and
okay so have any of you play the
Slenderman game yeah okay okay so
they're you know they're like ten
locations right yeah there's like the
blue pickup truck the red pickup truck
you know it's like yeah I know I
wouldn't say my gaming knowledge is very
good when it comes to like being under
pressure I do know my League of Legends
I know my job low what role do you play
in League of Legends and what's your
favorite champion oh I play ad carry and
ash usually I also like jinx okay so I
tend to play those a lot of farming the
turrets to what rank are you yeah I
really just researched her master at
best
[Music]
you had been slain so back to the
original question I asked before where I
said what's everyone's favorite video
games how about we just go around saying
like when you first play that games oh
me Kingdom Hearts is my favorite video
game ever like a huge part my life in
love that game store and read isn't my
favorite I even got you know why I got
to League was because of my friends from
another game we're all transitioning
over to League and then ever since then
I've just been playing that with my
girlfriend and their cousins well my
favorite game is pokemon emerald like
I've been playing emeralds it's a little
kid I remember I took me seven years to
beat battle dome and I'm over being so
excited that I pulled up the camera
immediately and started taking pictures
and posting it everywhere just huge
moment right there okay for me my
favorite game would probably be Paper
Mario the very first time I saw the game
my brother played it and I loved it and
my favorite game is until dawn which we
started playing in college my friend
brie was playing it in her living room
and then since then like I've probably
like played it I can't even count
so cross reference time yeah so your
first run who died he died like like the
first person who died or like it was the
couple the [ __ ] girl who is Veronica
and then yeah there's no Veronica in the
game oh there is no there is not
[Music]
what is the name of the monster in the
game well I could tell you what it's
like wow I did try to like but in like
hey let's move it but it was it was like
a wall the club window goes by the way
when he goes yeah there when it goes
there's a Veronica I look it up I
promise you there's Veronica I promise
there is no Veronica honestly my mind
went blank when she asked me about like
oh like about a character or something
like I couldn't think of a character's
names I could only think like the actors
and actresses so I said Veronica there
was just just a little shred of thought
of me thinking you know what like it's
hard being put on the spot Veronica she
split she was black hair short black
hair she has a little more right here
brown eyes she's like the [ __ ] one
he's like oh like she's like the asian
girl yeah is Ashley
no it's Veronica I don't know why you're
trying to tell me like okay her name's
Jessica I'm in the wrong and sonic
adventures - okay
there is no okay I don't have a lead
knowledge I know you do can you okay so
what role do you usually play okay so
you're like mid yeah okay I tend to play
Lux Soraka sona and annie annie support
norman both yeah
um how about cool questions what what is
a last name you guys bought like the
latest one you just bought
last game that I bought I may have to
come back to that because Ivan bought a
game no oil
I have Humble Bundle so I get like a
bundle of games like every month do you
don't read the last game you got liked
from the Humble Bundle the last game I
got from the Humble Bundle
see I got slayed spire which was like
maybe 2 months ago I haven't checked
this recent month yet but yeah slay the
spire I got that one you have been slain
can we get a little formation real quick
yes let's not want you boy
you're like you don't all are just like
like I have a Gamecube but like I
probably play like what C so that was
the truth in school I didn't really have
any friends apart like one or two and
then one day I found maplestory and I
started playing that and then I met some
people on there that's what really got
me into gaming cuz I found people who
just like me I became some of my best
friends I guess next time learn the
names of characters better yeah I knew I
knew it was over for me when I couldn't
answer because I truthfully I'm not
purchased a game in a few months but
because we are such a small group I
think that the guys were you know more
understanding they were like you know
what the girls it doesn't mean they're
not gamers you know hello thank you for
watching this episode of odd man out I'm
so happy you watched it feel free to
comment like subscribe follow us on
Instagram follow me on instagram follow
our director photography Adrian on
Instagram really anyone you want
do you have an Instagram follow Gabe our
sound guy on Instagram anyone just you
know consume
[Music]